well hey there you sad sack of [ __ ]
have you ever wanted a pet of your very
own well then why not get rock there's
so many things you can do with rock cook
with rock give your meal some pizzazz
wash your rock while you listen to jazz
can sit on the couch and watch it if
what you're watching is a little sleazy
you smell all the flowers on a bright
sunny day you can play hide and seek
send your troubles away block will
always be there for you every day never
escape how sexy that rock is now I know
this sounds too good to be true but for
just $10 you can have a rock
just go - markiplier comm / rock to see
what rock can do from you wash your car
to make it shine you can season your up
and make it a supply but don't get your
rock whatever you do we're serious about
this one please do not eat the rock you
can drink with rock to forget your
trouble even though you [ __ ] acts took
your goldfish bub and then stomp down
your dreams and pour out your heart but
please be aware that rock can't actually
talk rock talk please alert the SCP
foundation to be deep sleep with your
rock no we won't judge even though
you've got a pet bed already loves can't
deny that rock is a little sexy if you
want to keep freaky than rockets raise
your teeth with rockets as easy as pie
if you don't brush rock every hour
you'll die boss rock you know the box
the only friend that you wanna keep Rock
likes to watch you when you sleep
[Music]
all these amazing features can be yours
for only $10 yes
this is real it is not a dream but your
dreams have come true please go -
markiplier calm / Rock and get yourself
a rock today that is markiplier calm /
rock and if you order now I'll even
throw in free shipping
[Music]